mais elle continue place aux grands
débats on va s'arrêter sur l' annonce ou
plutôt la confirmation du jour l'ena
école nationale d'administration sera
bien supprimée et remplacée par un autre
système de formation de nos hauts
fonctionnaires qui s'appellera
l'institut du service public
emmanuel macron l'avait déjà promis à
l'issue de la crise et gilet jaune mais
depuis l'idée avait été un petit peu
mise entre parenthèses
avant de débattre du bien fondé ou pas
de cette suppression va revenir sur les
hésitations les atermoiements autour de
ce dossier c'est avec jordan plein
c'était il ya deux ans emmanuel macron
alors confronté à la crise des gilet
jaune annonce son intention de supprimer
l'ena l'école nationale d'administration
je pense que pour faire la réforme que
j'évoquais il faut supprimer entre
autres l'ena mais pas pour se donner
plaisir de supprimer les normes pour
bâtir quelque chose qui fonctionne mieux
telles que je les nie depuis le sujet
n'avait plus été évoquée pas l'exécutif
jusqu'à aujourd'hui dans une réunion cet
après-midi en visioconférence avec
quelques centaines de hauts
fonctionnaires
le président annonce sa décision
supprimés lena une nouvelle école
devrait la remplacer avec une
gouvernance différentes
l'immobilisme est plus fort que toutes
les énergies déployées mais est-ce que
ça c'est en supprimant les nac tout ça
va changer
mais c'est en réfléchissant à mode de
sélection et de formation qui soit
différent emmanuel macron souhaite
attirer des profils différents plus
variés dans les hautes fonctions de
l'état que sont l'inspection des
finances le conseil d'état ou la cour
des comptes
mais dans les rangs de l'opposition
cette annonce fait grincer des dents à
droite comme à gauche comme il est
question beaucoup des riches d
importants des ministres alors l'équipe
la team macron a trouvé une parade ce
matin j'ai tu as mangé les
fonctionnaires au pays en disant nous
allons supprimer l'ena ans pourquoi ça
veut dire maintenant mais survient pour
ça comme ça on va pouvoir jeter des
pierres aux hauts fonctionnaires
à l'état bon tout ça c'est de la
politique aille à mesure que jamais
l'état n'a été autant centralisée
bureaucratisée le problème ce n'est pas
les gars le problème c'est le politique
qui doit diriger son administration
avec cette annonce le symbole est fort
le président de la république souhaite
réformer l'ordonnancé qui a créé lna
celle du 9 octobre 1945 du général de
gaulle sur l'organisation de la haute
fonction publique avec nous pour ce
grand débat en direct sur public sénat
vincent jauvert bienvenue vous êtes
grand reporter à l'ops hauteur de ces
deux livres les voraces les élites et
l'argent sont macron et sept autres
livres les intouchables d'état bienvenue
en macro ni amine mbarki est également
avec nous bien venu vous êtes élue
socialiste à montreuil vous enseigner à
l'école polytechnique vous êtes hauts
fonctionnaires ont surchargé mission sur
les questions économiques au cabinet de
françois hollande si je ne me trompe pas
vous êtes diplômé de sciences po paris
de l'université de grenoble est donc de
l'ena irene à bâle d'aquino bienvenue à
vous également vous êtes essayiste
magistrate vous avez notamment publié
notre insatiable désir de magie dans
lequel vous parler des erreurs des
manuels macron et que vous appelez des
ans le dernier roi des énarques je crois
vous êtes diplômé vous aussi de l'ena et
en 2015 vous avez publié la ferme des
énarques jacques grosperrin est
également avec nous bien venu vous êtes
sénateur à l'ère du doubs secrétaire du
sénat membre de la commission de la
culture de l'éducation et de la
communication vous êtes vice président
de la mission d'information sur la
politique en faveur de l'égalité des
chances et d'émancipation la jeunesse et
vous êtes professeur agrégé membre du
conseil d'administration de l'ena dans
quatre personnes parfaitement concernés
par le sujet ce soir emmanuel macron la
voulait cette suppression de l'ena puis
plus vraiment puis de nouveau ce soir
ils annoncent officiellement il la
remplace par l'institut du service
public liesp et vincent jauvert c'était
un vrai sujet il a bien fait en
symboliquement certainement oui
dans l'histoire il ya eu que deux
créations ou
renaissance d'école du service public se
sont toujours ça s'est toujours passé à
près d'une très très grave crise était
1872 la création de l'école des sciences
politiques
l'école libre des sciences politiques à
l'époque et 45 la création de l'ena donc
symboliquement il dit aux français j'ai
compris la crise générale sociale
politique sanitaire est très grave
alors il fallait at il commencé par là
fallait-il faire cela comme ça
fallait-il redessiné l'école de l'ena
puisque en fait c'est ça qui se passe il
redessine l'ena si il fallait le faire
sans doute mais il me semble que le plus
important c'est de s'occuper des grands
corps de la replace incommensurables
dans la société en termes à la fois dans
l'administration dans la politique et
dans l'économie de sa diffusion
donc on n'aura pas distinguer tant qu'on
n'aura pas fait sortir en quelque sorte
les hauts fonctionnaires de la vie
politique et de la vie économique privé
la france sera ce score qui a du mal
avec soin avec ses élites amine mbarki
vous voulez saluer vous cette décision
d' emmanuel masson vous l'a regretté
profondément
qu'est ce que c'est pour vous une chasse
aux élites gelé l'ena bouc émissaire
comment comment vous qualifier cette
cette prise de décision il ya 12 et n'a
en fait il ya les nains symbole et je
pense que c'est assez tena symbole qui
manuel macron s'attaque
cet après midi et puis c'est pas la
première fois qu'il annonçait des ventes
à fin mars est pas la première fois
qu'un président de la république
souhaiterait fin mai elle a donc quelque
chose vient de loin avec cette critique
en creux des élites qu'il faut aussi
entendre qu'il faut aussi faire évoluer
puisque derrière ça il ya toutes les
grandes prises de décision du pays qui
sont prises par ces personnes là alors
tant que cette élite est un peu refermée
sur elle-même qu'elle n'est pas ouverte
sur l'ensemble de la population il y
aura toujours cette critique lna en lte
mais vous par exemple en tant qu énarque
vous le prenez mal non de là on
s'attaque à quelque chose qui moi ma
forme et je le regrette c'est pas la
rage qu'il est le symbole
et c'est ça qui est aujourd'hui en jeu
mais derrière ça il ya l'école qui forme
des milliers de serviteurs du service
public ce qu'on ne voit pas ce qu'ils
n'ont pas la télévision ce que qui
travaillent d'arrache-pied pour faire en
sorte que le pays fonctionne au mieux et
depuis d'ailleurs des années et des
années que ce soit d'ailleurs des élèves
de l'ena ou deux élèves d'autres écoles
du service public il ya ces serviteurs
de sa celui qui est l'enjeu principal
c'est de savoir qu'est ce qu'on veut
faire de cette école est ce qu'on veut
ou non pas une école qui forme les
cadeaux il s'agit malheureusement quoi
c'est pas le nom
uniquement si ce qu'on veut en faire
jacques grosperrin comment vous la voyez
cette annonce c'est une entendu beaucoup
de choses à mesure des magots un cadeau
fait au gilet jaune ou aux anti élites
c'est quoi pour vous moi j'ai ce
sentiment que c'est un coup de com les
présidents de la république et ça ça
peut être un comportement de d'un
énarque et arrogant alors que je pense
que c'est la sombre sont par au moins je
pense qu'il ya d'autres priorités en ce
moment dans le cadre de la pandémie et
c'est que du ski est beaucoup plus
populiste alors il avait promis aux
rouges et les jaunes de le supprimer
je pense que c'est aussi pour montrer
qu'il revient sur ses promesses qui et
décide de faire ce qu'il a dit au départ
mais je suis pas persuadé que dans une
période aussi difficile qu'on vit en ce
moment ce soit vraiment une priorité
et puis je suis choquée sur la forme je
suis choquée moi je suis membre du
conseil d'administration je ne suis pas
sûr que le président le directeur de
l'ena et est apprécié d'apprendre cela
par les médias et puis enfin sur le fond
c'est toujours pareil ses 11 saisons les
réflexes révolutionnaire qu'on retrouve
en france on n'aime pas les éditos
n'aime pas les élus on n'aime pas les
patrons
je crois que mon année il ya une vraie
réflexion à avoir il faut être fier des
gens qui réussissent
il faut être fier de de ceux qui
quittent flic forêts bien qu'il y ait
une vraie réplique une vraie réflexion
vous savez depuis 2000 18-24 du causse
administration ya une vraie réforme qui
a été mise en place par le président
avec une ouverture de dans ce qu'on
appelle les talents des cités et c'est
dommage et un quatrième concours
d'ailleurs qui ouvert au doctor who les
scientifiques parce que j'ai entendu
tout à l'heure qu'on disait que c'était
pas ces scientifiques il ya une deuxième
classe pour de préparation intégré pour
l'égalité des chances donc il y avait
vraiment une belle orientation qui se
met en place
j'ai l'impression qu'il est en train de
casser quelque chose pour faire plaisir
à un ensemble de français pour dire on
va écouter les chants encore là
[Musique]
les les réformes continuent et vous
verrez on va arriver
j'ai entendu un homme de l'institut moi
je parlais je pensais qu'elle a précisé
l'institut national du service public
n'aurait l'idée c'est pas le problème de
la formation de l'ena les étudiants qui
sortent le professionnel qui sort ce
sont deux très bien formés les pays
étrangers en sont très fiers cette
problème de ce qu'on en fait après il
faut faire en sorte de les faire sortie
de ceux de ce microcosme parisien pour
les mettre un peu plus on passe des
réalités a dit adeline baldacchino
comment comment vous voyez cela vous
avez l'âme sans qu emmanuel macron est
tombé dans un piège dans le piège de la
démagogie ou qu'au contraire ils
s'attaquent un vrai sujet vous qui
étudié cette question depuis pas mal de
temps quand même si on voulait être un
peu ironique on dirait que emmanuel
macron envie d'être le dernier roi des
énarques le dernier des énarques et à la
fois son exemple le plus abouti
finalement une de ses plus grandes
réussites
à peine sorti président quelques années
plus tard et en même temps on voit bien
que cette annonce vient d'abord en
pleine crise des gilet jaune
ensuite au moment d'une crise sanitaire
profonde
il faut s'interroger et sur les raisons
de ce calendrier parce que c'est un
serpent de mer finalement la question de
l'ena depuis des années et pourquoi ça
arrive comme ça et pourquoi ça arrive
aussi brutalement parce que en effet
enfin brutalement après des volte face
des annonces qui ont plusieurs années et
puis qui ont disparu et puis qui
reviennent mais brutalement au sens du
mode de gouvernance et d'une façon
d'annoncer verticalement qui correspond
vraiment à une façon d'exercer le
pouvoir qui est extrêmement verticale en
dix ans en effet du jour au lendemain en
faisant apparaître dans le dans
l'actualité on va supprimer cette école
en informant très probablement personne
même pas le directeur de l'école et moi
je crois que ce qui se cache derrière
c'est aussi une volonté effectivement de
trouver des responsables de se défausser
un peu sur la haute fonction publique
qui fait malgré tout en effet de son
mieux dans d un cadre très compliqué en
oubliant la responsabilité du politique
de la politique de la manière de faire
de la politique et que c'est pour ça que
ça arrive maintenant alors que le vrai
sujet autour de l'ena est un sujet j'ai
envie de dire beaucoup plus prosaïque et
d'une certaine manière mais beaucoup
plus profond de tout ça qui est certes
ce qu'on fait des gens une fois qu'ils
sont sortis mais j'ai envie de dire que
les carrières on s'en moque un peu pour
le en tout cas pour le citoyen lambda il
n'est pas très intéressé de savoir si on
va faire une carrière extraordinaire
fulgurante ou pas le vrai sujet c'est
pas ça c'est comment être formés à
l'école d'une manière qui nous rendent
le plus utile possible le plus
opérationnel possible le plus en prise
avec la société d'une manière impeccable
en termes éthiques et pour sal
ordonnance de 45 initial qui a créé
l'ena et qui disait on l'a créée pour
donner aux hauts fonctionnaires
le sentiment des devoirs que le cette
fonction publique implique
je crois qu'elle était très juste et au
fond on aboutit la un processus qui est
en fait un processus de néo
libéralisation pour employer des grands
mots et de privatisation des modes de
recrutement de l'état qui ne va régler
aucun des problèmes de fond que peut
poser là l'uniformité parfois
idéologique de la formation à laquelle
il faudrait en effet pouvoir s'attaquer
vous avez raison de remonter à 40 fois
que moi j'ai été chercher du côté de
l'allocution du général de gaulle en 59
le 17 novembre lors de sa visite de
l'ena de gaulle dira ceci il fallait que
ceux qui servent au premier rang
constitue une élite intellectuelle et
morale
alors il ya effectivement cette question
de calendrier qui interroge il faut dire
que la crise qu vide est passée par là
alors elle a pour certains révélé ou
confirmé un problème d'efficacité de nos
hauts fonctionnaires procès injustes ou
pas vous me direz ce que vous en pensez
c'est en tout cas l'objet d'une tribune
au film fun post signé par plusieurs
dizaines d'agents publics des différents
horizons d'entrepreneurs qui nous disent
après la crise qu vite comment rendre la
haute fonction publique plus
opérationnel notre pays a besoin de
hauts fonctionnaires praticiens pour
répondre concrètement aux problèmes du
moment pour changer le réel il faut des
hauts fonctionnaires qui ont pratiqué ce
réel fin de citation alors la crise qu
vide at elle été un nouveau détonateur
pour emmanuel macron jours et qu'on
écoute gabriel atta le porte parole du
gouvernement qui en a dit un mot c'est
assez subtil écoutez bien mais il parle
de cette crise vous savez la volonté de
briser les corporatismes et d'avoir une
haute fonction publique plus efficace
plus attractive plus souple plus à
l'image de la société a été exprimée par
le président de la république dès le
début du quinquennat
beaucoup de mesures beaucoup de
réflexions ont été lancés je pense
notamment au rapport est sérieuse je
pense être à la mise en place il ya
quelques semaines où vous en souvenez le
président de la république l'avait
annoncé dans un déplacement
la mise en place d'une voie d'accès
spéciale pour les boursiers aux écoles
de la fonction publique
le président avait évoqué encore une
fois tous ces sujets notamment l ena en
avril 2019 et donc je peux vous dire et
c'est ce que traduit la réunion de cet
après-midi et l'intervention du
président de la république c'est que
notre volonté de réformer la haute
fonction publique est intacte et je
dirais même que la crise l'a renforcée
et l'a finalement décupler la crise l'a
renforcé l'a finalement décuplée vincent
jauvert est ce que cette crise coville a
été une nouvelle étape qui a pu montrer
les défaillances possibles de hauts
fonctionnaires qui n'ont pas su gérer ou
alors est ce qu'il maniait macro ce
défaut sur un peu des deux on peut les
deux évidemment on a vu les catastrophes
notamment au niveau des ars parfois
évidemment mc ren a besoin de boucs
émissaires
moi ce qui me frappe dans ce qui est dit
c'est que on a besoin de gens compétents
dans les domaines
pourquoi at on besoin d'une école mais
le seul pays au monde à peu près à avoir
une école pour former des hauts
fonctionnaires
il ya d'autres pays qui fonctionne
plutôt pas trop mal comme l'allemagne
qui emploie des gens qui viennent de
l'université ou d'ailleurs des gens
compétents dans leur domaine
pourquoi avoir besoin d administrateurs
généraux qui en gros quand ils arrivent
ne savent rien faire et on estime que
parce qu'ils ont fait de bonnes études
en la capacité de gérer des choses mais
moi je me demande pourquoi il ya
beaucoup de responsables de rs qui sont
des conseillers d'état grand dieu est ce
parce que c'est un poste très bien payés
qu'il faut recaser les les conseillers
ministériels c'est souvent le cas alors
on va me traiter de populiste mais c'est
pourtant la vérité
en réalité je pense pas qu'on ait besoin
d'une école on a besoin de classe et
même l'idée même du général de gaulle
que vous remettez en question nommé
général de gaulle ça venait d'ailleurs
ça venait de la résistance saison des
gens qui voulaient se séparer de deux
lames de l'élite d'avant et en former
une nouvelle plus démocratique plus
ouverte ça a été un échec un échec qui a
été noté tout de suite
dix ans après ça fait soixante dix ans
que l'ensemble de la classe politique y
compris les ceux qui venaient avant
l'ère les jacques chirac
souvenez vous de la campagne 95 de
jacques chirac puisse 96 que disait-il
ils perdent disait exactement la même
chose que macron il faut supprimer l'ena
il faut supprimer cette technocratie
dont il était et lui n'a rien fait
emmanuel macron pas grand chose non plus
donc cette école est son problème c'est
qu'elle le sait les promotions notamment
parmi les multiples choses sont les
promotions
vous connaissez la promotion voltaire
l'équipe l'équipe hollande
la combustion senghor voilà amine mbarki
vous avez peut-être envie de répondre
vous aussi vous avez vraiment promotion
est ce que cette crise a pu être aussi
un détonateur et ce qu'elle a révélé une
forme de défaillance de sept de ses
hauts fonctionnaires je crois pas que
tous les énarques se valent je crois pas
que tous les hauts fonctionnaires ce
ballon peut pas dire que tous sont
mauvais tous sont très bons il ya une
grande diversité de profils et à s'il ya
eu des défaillances
elles tiennent autant à la personne et
ce qu'elle a pu faire que cette
information antérieure formation
pareille hausse est plus lié à des
individus qu'à une espèce de formatage
qui nous auraient déconnecté de la
réalité je crois pas
en fait je pense que le la moitié des
élèves de l'ena d'abord on fait des
choses avant puisque la moitié d'une
promotion c'est des fonctionnaires qui
ont parfois long parcours derrière eux
et qu'ils utilisent lennar pour une
avancée professionnels ce qui d'ailleurs
sont sur son objectif et donc je mathus
le cinéma je parle dans le privé et une
partie de la production conclusion plus
d'une dizaine d'années d'expérience et
qui vous feront l'état des gens perché
dans un entre soi la gare la voiture
également la critique cible l'autre
moitié c'est à dire de jean lurçat
retenait des mêmes écoles slr voilà
l'enjeu
bonjour il n'est pas tant de savoir si à
l'ena on est plus ou moins bien formés
c'est une question elle est importante
mais c'est aussi de voir qu'est ce qui
se cache derrière la sélection au
concours d'entrée et à l'accès à ces
écoles ce qui devrait à mon avis changé
et ça a été rappelé c'est de faire en
sorte que toutes les catégories scolaire
sociale à un moment donné se disent on
est en mesure d'accéder à ces concours
il ya une forme de vocation au service
public qui se traduit par la possibilité
de passer ces concours il les concours
sont aujourd'hui concentrés sur une
présérie vauban doute sélection
d'athlètes la plupart des élèves ont
fait sciences po avant la plupart ont
fait les bonnes des bons des bons lycées
bref la sélection le formatage s'il
devait en avoir un il fallait là il est
beau bien au delà
donc ça tout info il ya tout un tout un
cycle avant et c'est là l'enjeu
principal c'est de voir comment est ce
que l'on diversifie les
source de recrutement pour faire en
sorte que ceux qui arrivent à l'ena soit
plus divers que ceux qui sont
aujourd'hui l'hymne baldacchino vous qui
parliez de ce calendrier la crise qu
vide a forcément joué dans cette annonce
du jour il me semble il ya eu d'abord la
crise gilet jaune ensuite la crise que
vides
il faut essayer d'avoir des effets de
nantes comme ça qu'ils soient positifs
parce que on croit que ça répond à une
attente probablement complètement
fantasmée et imaginaire en fait de la
société je ne crois pas que la priorité
aujourd'hui des gens soit 2,2 de savoir
comment va s'appeler l'école qui formera
les hauts fonctionnaires là le vrai le
vrai sujet c'est de se demander pourquoi
on se focalise aujourd'hui à ce point là
sur sur cette formation et et de
comprendre pourquoi on n'arrive pas à se
défendre l'idée qu'il puisse y avoir en
effet un socle commun relevant d'une
vision de ce qu'est l'action publique de
ce que sont les communs de ce qu'est le
bien commun qui impose peut-être d'avoir
à un moment donné un passage par un
institut une école peu importe un
endroit où l'on apprend à servir les
autres avant de se servir soi même et ça
je crois que ça reste une vraie
différence est assez fondamentale avec
les types de recrutement plus classique
qu'on peut avoir dans le dans le privé
donc il ya une histoire certes qui
explique la création de l'ena mais j'ai
envie de dire que la période très
particulière que l'on vit elle
justifierait largement une vocation de
l'ena qui ressemblerait à celle que
défend des de gaulle où à l'époque
thorez puisque c'était à la fois un
gaullistes et les communistes de vouloir
une école un peu particulière qui soit
une forme de sas d'entrée dans le sang
vi public en tant qu'il n'est pas la
même chose que la recherche du profit
pour dire les choses extrêmement
simplement et cette vocation là je pense
qu'elle reste légitime et qu'il faudrait
pas jeter le bébé du haut fonctionnaire
avec le bain de l'école et renoncer à à
7 à cette vocation au nom de voir la
dune d'un institut du service public qui
sonne j'ai envie de dire très
managériale certes mais est-ce que ça va
beaucoup nous avancer nous avancées en
termes de compétences j'entendais ce mot
là tout à l'heure évidemment c'est ça
qui est important c'est que les gens qui
en sortent suffisamment bien formés pour
être au bon endroit au bon moment non
pas parce qu'ils ont une étiquette sur
le front celle des narcos celle de
conseiller d'état ou autres mais parce
qu'ils sont bons là où ils sont et je
crois qu'il ya un certain nombre de
métiers au sein de l'état de
coordination de koné qui implique une
connaissance très particulière de l'état
et pas seulement un recrutement direct à
la sortie en fait de quoi ce serait un
sort à la sortie de sciences po où ce
serait à la sortie des écoles de
commerce il je suis pas sûr qu'on
améliore en faisant ça
la qualité du service public et jacques
grosperrin oui moi je pense que de
l'écrit où nous voulons mettre en place
une nouvelle icône qui permettrait à
d'autres
le formation d'une fonctionnaire de
sortir c'est peut-être une bonne idée
mais si c'est refaire la même école avec
le même principe
elle ne pas permettre cette mobilité
après parce que je crois que c'est ça la
difficulté faut absolument ces hauts
fonctionnaires puissent être mobile dans
tous les domaines d'administration mais
également être puis celles alliées
d'encre uv dans le public et c'est je
crois c'est important lorsqu'on disait
tout à l'heure l'ouverture à la
diversité vous savez en 2010 9 39% des
désirs 36% des des étudiants qui étaient
candidats au concours étaient des
candidats boursiers donc c'est un faux
problème
moi je voudrais revenir quand même je
pense que c'est une manière de faire
oublier les couacs
c'est une manière pour le président la
république de se déresponsabiliser
vis-à-vis de l'exécutif il est important
de le dire
les hauts fonctionnaires sont au service
des élus s'y abandonner les hauts
fonctionnaires prennent
sur les élus c'est que les élus les
exécutifs ne fait pas son travail
ensuite
regardez le nombre de ministres qui ont
réussi l'ena ou qu'on fait sciences po
qui sont autour de d'emmanuel macron
donc si à un moment donné il voulait
remettre en cause la formation l'
équilibre
je crois qu'il aurait fait peut-être
aussi appel à peut-être beaucoup plus de
diversité donc moi je pense que que
c'est un faux problème que l'on que l'on
fait à l'ena c'est une manière de de se
défausser de l'ancien a pavé dans la
marre de parler d'autre chose de ne pas
régler les problèmes de pandémie de
vaccins etc
ce n'est pas que la france la
responsabilité je l'entends la
responsabilité des ars il est vrai mais
à un moment donné il y as patron le
patron c'est lille uc prennent la
république et sa responsabilité est
véritablement engagée à vous êtes
complètement en phase avec le patron de
votre groupe au sénat qu'on va écouter
dans un instant pour le patron des
sénateurs est là bruno retailleau on en
arrive là parce que le politique a
failli bien plus que les élites écouter
le problème ce n'est pas les gars le
problème c'est le politique qui doit
diriger son administration qui est dit
privilège qu'il faille mettre fin à des
privilèges parce que parfois on en crée
en france des allées et venues entre le
public le privé où on retrouve davantage
oui mais on a besoin d'une élite je vous
disais il ya quelques instants que
j'étais patron département j'étais pas
tant de régions et j'ai eu au sommet de
la pyramide de mai administration de
jeunes énarques
je peux vous dire que j'en retire le
chapeau c'était des gens de très grande
qualité simplement c'est pas eux qui me
dirigeais c'est moi qui les dirigeait
vincent jauvert oui oui la raison
certainement
alors ce qui est étrange c'est que c'est
que les hommes politiques sont pour
beaucoup énarque est essentiellement
issus des grands corps pour moi le sujet
célèbre encore le reste la masse de
l'ena sont des gens qui font leur métier
normalement mal pays en général
et donc ces hommes politiques issus des
grands corps notre premier ministre
notre président le premier ministre
d'avant lors que l'ordre enfin
l'ensemble de l'aude qui sont autour
d'eux écoutez y aurait une chose très
simple à faire une loi qui est celle qui
est que qui est en grande bretagne et
qui n'est pas le dernier pays en matière
de démocratie qui est très simple tout
fonctionnaire mais en général les eaux
qui veut entrer en politique doit
démissionner c'est tout démissionner
deux de la fonction publique notre notre
paysage politique serait radicalement
changé on aurait des hommes politiques
en politique on aurait des
fonctionnaires fonctionnaires mais pas
les deux et si en plus son métier une
petite dose de lait opl et hauts
fonctionnaires en général ceux qui
veulent pantoufles et ne peuvent pas
pantoufler avant cinq ans il n'a pas
trois ans parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est une
pub trois ans et dans le secteur qu'ils
ont contrôlé pendant cinq ans on
n'aurait pas le même paysage économique
pour moi le problème il est là l'ena
c'est une école qui forme très mal ils
le disent tous deux les générations de
d'énarques notamment la promotion macron
écrivent tous à leur ministre de tutelle
pour dire est sûrement le ciel de madame
on est mal formés c'est n'importe quoi à
part les stages
pourquoi parce que c'est classé parce
que leur objectif est le classement
c'est pas de formules ces deux classés
et sa emmanuel macron dans son institut
classé pour de rentrer dans les grands
corps dans les cases les grands corps
les autres tout le monde s'en moque
c'est pourtant le canton reste occupée
et donc c'est sur le plan législatif en
tout cas qu'on pourrait faire quelque
chose c'est très simple alors jacques
grosperrin peut-être envie de très
simple ça peut vous inspirez très très
simple oui oui on peut faire quelque
chose
vous avez raison mais je suis pas
persuadé que le fait
et aux énarques de démissionner
lorsqu'ils s'engagent en politique on
l'a vu d'ailleurs certains l'ont fait
bruno le maire l'a fait d'autres l'ont
fait je suis pas persuadé que ça soit la
solution
moi je pense qu'il est il est important
de mettre en place certainement une
nouvelle école qui puisse comme je le
disais plus tôt leur permettre deux de
former des futurs hauts fonctionnaires
et je pense que la réussite de cette
école dépendra essentiellement de
l'agilité de la mobilité que l'on
donnera au delà de l'information c'est
ce qu'on fera des fonctionnaires une
fois qu'ils sortiront de ces écoles sans
oublier qu'ils sont au service des élus
qui les élus sont au service de la
population s'est mise à la france eminem
marquer il faut pas à mon avis faire de
faux procès s'il ya eu certaines
défaillances a été dit des privilèges
des pantouflage dans le privé qui
peuvent amener à des conflits d'intérêts
il faut que ça cesse effectivement et
c'est planina n'est pas fait pour ça et
elle n'a jamais été fait pour ça d'un
autre côté ne pas oublier que d'une part
cette école est la vocation à former des
gens pour servir l'administration pour
servir le pays
et moi je pense juste très attaché à la
question de l'école parce qu'il ya là si
derrière la question du concours dont
toute la fonction publique ce soit la
fonction publique d'état hospitalière
territoriale
il ya d'abord un concours qui permet
derrière d'être intégré une école pour
se former
l'ena n'est qu'une école parmi tant
d'autres parce que ce concours
il permet à l'instant t de mettre tout
le monde sur un pied d'égalité
alors évidemment il faut qu'avant ça il
y ait les mêmes chances pour chacun d'où
la création ça a été cité d'une filière
spécifique menée par personne qui sont
peut-être plus éloignés des codes
classiques de sciences po etc
mais le concours elle cet avantage est
supprimé ça ça entraîne le risque que
l'administration soit au gang rennais
par la cooptation comme cet ex qu'avant
l'ena c'est dire que si vous voulez
devenir les être diplomate
il fallait être fils de diplomate voilà
l avec le concours vous avez des
centaines de profils dont les parents
n'ont
jamais était fonctionnaire ils sont loin
des catégories aisées et qui ont pu
intégrer l'administration et servir à
des très belles responsabilités leur
pays adeline baldacchino je pense
qu'effectivement sur la question du
pantouflage et des conflits d'intérêts
là il ya quelque chose à faire
voilà si on veut renforcer la confiance
dans les personnes qui oeuvrent au
service de l'intérêt général et ne pas
avoir toujours un doute ou un petit
warning qui s'allument dans un coin de
l'esprit parce qu'on se demande si ils
n'ont pas en retirer un intérêt
personnel là il ya vraiment quelque
chose à faire sur ces passages publics
privés qui sont devenus une sorte de
tarte à la crème moderne on dit faut
absolument les favorisés parce que c'est
formidable d'amener et osant les
compétences des autres et ça devient en
fait eu une passoire et l'alibi parfait
pour percy faire tout ce qu'il faut pour
ensuite aller travailler dans le secteur
qu'on régule et quelques mois plus tôt
et gagner beaucoup d'argent donc là
dessus on pourrait en effet agir pour le
reste je pense en effet qu'il faut pas
remplacer le classement par le réseau et
par la cooptation parce que c'est ce qui
nous pend au nez
dès qu'on sort d'un régime de de
concours ou qu'on essaye d'objectiver
d'une manière ou d'une autre un mérite
même si on sait que le mérite a en effet
des origines sociales et que c'est
compliqué qu'il faut agir le plus tôt
possible au niveau de l'école très tôt
et au niveau des prépas pour entrer à
l'ena en élargissant le plus possible
les voies d'accès c'est évident mais
surtout ne pas à les remplacer même un
classement par au fond des entretiens
individuels entre amis de bonne famille
qui se seraient repérés depuis des
années et qui pourrait entrer encore
plus vite dans les grands corps merci
merci infiniment désolés de vous couper
un peu brutalement mais le chrono tourne
merci en tout cas à tous d'avoir
participé à ce débat si vous avez envie
d'aller plus loin d'ailleurs sur le
sujet je vous invite à regarder un
mondant dogues ce samedi à 21h vous
pourrez découvrir le documentaire
d'emilie longs sont et d'alix étourneaux
ena pourquoi tant de haine
suivi d'un débat animé par notre
confrère jérôme chapuis c'est la fin de
cette émission elle revient lundi à 18
heures et 22 heures avec ma collègue
femme tran huy moi je vous retrouverai
la semaine suivante
demain bonjour chez vous délocalisez à
marseille 17h30 émission spéciale au
rayonnement de chimie recevra le maire
de la ville benoît payan et renaud
muselier président de la région sud je
vous souhaite une excellente soirée son
public ses marques
[Musique]